and everybody's like Tim Burton's never
done television four days later we heard
back Tim read the script he loved it he
wants to get on a on a call with you to
talk about it and Mike Simpson's his
agent who's a huge agent over at wme's
Quentin Tarantino and and we said oh
great well he set up a zoom or something
he goes no I'm going to send you Tim's
number and you can FaceTime him tomorrow
because he lives he lives in England so
we did and it was like a classic where
was your mom has this this place in near
Oxford this beautiful like country
estate and the garden is filled with
these life-sized dinosaur like statues
so he's standing there in his dinosaur
Garden talking to us on his on his and
losing reception it was just like The
Surreal moving around we're like we
can't believe we're talking and he's
like I love the script he goes like are
you nervous yes because it's Timbers